bonjour implanter un tramway est un
geste technique mais c'est avant tout un
moment de réflexion sur l'organisation
de la ville ainsi à l'occasion de la
deuxième ligne de tramway à orléans une
étude pendant six ans était mené une
étude pour mieux cerner la cohabitation
possible entre usages et usagers de la
ville
le tramway son trajet ces stations son
rythme son fonctionnement ont une
incidence directe sur nos vies urbaines
car le tramway transforment le paysage
vu et vécu l'agglomération et la ville
d'orléans ont choisi de dépasser la
simple implantation technique du tram
pour repenser l'organisation de la ville
kiara bonino architecte paysagiste est
la conceptrice et réalisatrice de la
deuxième ligne du tram
un travail sur six années ici la place
de-gaulle à l'origine une place
résiduelle du à la reconstruction après
guerre jamais vraiment pensé la place
n'était qu'un lieu de passage des
différents moyens de transport c'était
une place qui n'en était pas une parce
qu'il y avait ça fonctionnait pas très
bien ensuite la ligne une donc la
station de l'élastine de gaulle
d'aligner une était vraiment à
l'extrémité de la rue jeanne-d'arc donc
fonctionnellement sacrés rupture de
circulation piétonne même circulation
véhicules et donc en fait c'était un
petit peu un non-lieu c'était très
circuler c'était
il ya beaucoup de circulation piétonne
c'était plutôt fonctionnelle les gens ne
s'y arrêtaient pas fait le pari de kiara
une place piétonne vivante et qui
deviennent un lien entre l'hyper centre
et le quartier carmes
alors la place s'organise autour du
végétal et des chemins de circulation
plus fluide entre des espaces distincts
la première opération a été de déplacer
la station de la ligne une qui coupait
visuellement lax cathédrale carne ben
arbres parquet de pierre mobilier jouant
la transparence et d accès multiple
l'ensemble participe à pacifier un
espace dédié aux piétons sont des
éléments simples le sol
sa composition et comment ils agences et
des éléments de mobilier très simple d
les abris qui donne
la direction en fait de la place qui
forment les zones d'assises qui sont
travaillés de manière plus contemporaine
rue jeanne-d'arc pas de contemporains
mais une architecture néoclassique et
une proximité avec la cathédrale classée
monument historique
l'ensemble réclame un soin tout
particulier la ligne sans caténaire et
doit respecter la symétrie des lieux il
a été décidé en fait de installé cet axe
vert qui fait le lien entre la place
sainte croix et la place de gaulle avec
un dispositif de et basse taille et
enduits donc pérenne qui marque la
symétrie dans la cathédrale et qui
permet tout bonnement
le défilé au cours de fêtes de jeanne
d'arc s'en soucier
outre les impératifs techniques beaucoup
d'autres paramètres interviennent dans
la conception d'une ligne de tram
voitures piétons cyclistes pompiers
livraison voisinage sont autant d'usagés
d'usagers qui doivent pouvoir cohabiter
direction saint jean de braye pour un
exemple de partage de territoire entre
bus tram automobile et lycéens
le projet ici c'était de placer en fait
un pôle de change 30 bus face à un lycée
est donc une densité de population assez
élevée de la population vivent coire
donc comment insérer un pôle bus dans
une ville et en faire un morceau de
ville
donc le parti qui était retenu c'était
de créer un petit jardin devant le lycée
pour faire en sorte de faire un espace
d'accueil en espace tampon en fait entre
le lycée et le pote de change les
magnoacais les élèves puissent
s'y installer véritablement voir ce
qu'on a voulu faire s'inscrire dans
l'histoire de la ville et de réaliser
des lieux qui sont véritablement pérenne
qui est pas du passé mais qui sont
projetés vers le futur